you know the Chiefs one yeah the Chiefs
are in the Super Bowl
Richard now told the guys around here
what he's planning to do is go to Kansas
City for the Super Bowl and watch the
game outside because in Kansas City this
time of year people sit outside and
watch the the football games on a TV
together in a group right I'm Richard
said I wanna be with real fans now he's
gonna sit in the stadium are they doing
no no no stadium no lady you sit in
front of a bar but outside freezing
Jerry put Richards desk outside today
let's see how well even maybe that'll
wake him up what are you laughing at
you're really gonna get on a plane you
got a kid you're gonna fly to Kansas
City first off can I say how about them
Chiefs who are you so happy oh my god
[ __ ] tears really I don't watch
football what was the game close or was
it while they were down at the beginning
and then [ __ ] mahomes I'm gonna
[ __ ] cry he [ __ ] rules man how
come he's we have our quarterback
finally the Chiefs never they always got
quarterbacks from somewhere else this is
our [ __ ] guy and he told me on
wrap-up show last year he said we're
gonna get to Miami free you and your dad
and he [ __ ] did it
yeah in a parking lot a lot of money
Richard's got an enormous booger hanging
from his nose missing yeah it's like
it's not icicle I'm close to me let me
look at or you can see it come close I
still don't see it oh my god oh my god
[ __ ] is wrong with you get a tissue here
Scott yeah we don't know that was there
Jesus thanks Gary I didn't even know I'm
gonna throw up yeah oh here here's
Richard crying when he spoke to the
Chiefs quarterback on rapa you've just
brought so much happiness to people like
me and you know Chiefs fans I had so
much fun watching you this year you just
made us so happy this year and I I am so
excited for what's to come in the many
years ahead so thank you Patrick
no I appreciate it man appreciate
everything you said my hero is the guy
who shot bin Laden died when I meet him
yeah they're supposed to take the game
this seriously not you Hey just sit
there and watch as you know Mohammed's
like what the [ __ ] right he was like
this guy's crazy like I don't want this
guy anywhere near me appreciate
everything you said and hopefully we get
that Super Bowl for you here soon yeah I
hope to see you in Miami a year from now
Richard's going to be the parking lot
cornfield closed and cows [ __ ]